well if you ever thought that maybe
popular culture is one of the reasons
why Trump is president popular culture
is one of the reasons why Trump is
president every area of American life
has to be perverted for politics every
single one your latest example HGTV is
now featuring its first-ever throuple on
house hunters because what you wanted
was propaganda about how a married
couple who brought in a woman to live
with them and yes they have kids no one
gives a crap out to kids by the way
in these situations no one gives two
damns about the kids seriously because
this woman who's been brought in is not
biologically related to the kids she
doesn't know the kids she's being
brought in as a late addition to this
couples personal life but nobody of her
things like would it be good for the
kids just bring the stranger into our
house and have this person live with our
children like would that be a great idea
really nobody ever thinks of that but
this is apparently a moment of glory for
house hunters it's representation guys
representation of diverse sexual
orientations according to people calm
the episode is titled three's not a
crowd in Colorado Springs the family
came down with a list of must-haves for
their new reson including a three car
garage and a master bathroom that will
accommodate three people as you will see
from this clip it is pretty obvious that
the master bathroom is only meant to
accommodate two people but in any case
here is the here's a little bit of the
clip from from people talking about this
dumb episode HGTV made history on
Wednesday by featuring its first-ever
throuple in case you didn't know that's
three people in a polyamorous romantic
relationship they were on the very
popular show House honors take a look
Texans Brian Laurie and jelly do you
realize there's nothing conventional
about them we're a circle it's a
relationship that's three people not
just two there you go the episode titled
three is not a crowd in Colorado Springs
and it follows Brian what I'm about to
describe to you is absolutely 100% the
truth so the man in the Warner married
they brought in this other lady they met
her at a bar which first of all when you
go to a bar and you meet just a Rando
and then you're like what if we brought
you in and both married you there's
something wrong with your relationship
already I'm just gonna put it out there
that your relationship ain't going great
if you're if you're hitting up the bar
so you can bring other people into your
relationship as a person who's been
married for nearly 12 years I'm gonna
say you got a problem you've got a
problem okay but this picture
what it shows is the wife who looks
pretty excited to be on house hunters
and the female the the other female non
like wife not wife like they're not
formally married obviously that's not
legal yet it will be soon enough because
once you have devalue the institution of
marriage from man and woman getting
together to bear and we're children to
any number of people of any sex and
orientation who love each other then why
not why I mean seriously there's no
logical barrier to this obviously in any
case the two ladies look pretty happy
about situation and an O'Brien over here
looks like he is beginning to realize it
is now dawning upon him that his wife is
a lesbian right I mean that it's
actually what's happening in these clips
it's beginning to dawn on Brian that
what started off as a sexy sexy idea has
now resulted in him in the sidecar right
well they're on there it turns out
there's just two seats in that in that
in that front seat of the car an old
Brian's gonna be riding in the trunk
and that's dawning on Brian as this
episode goes on but you gotta love that
the media are now pushing the idea that
all forms of relationship are equivalent
wonderfully moral decent it's not just
HGTV by the way and if you if you
mentioned this it's because you're
intolerant intolerant now listen I don't
want any of this regulated I don't care
I mean I don't care in the sense that I
don't think the government should get
involved whatever floats your boat on
the governmental level however in terms
of what is best for the raising of
children what is best for sexual values
I'm not going to pretend that monogamous
relationships aren't just equivalent in
on every moral level with polyamorous
ones
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
benton shapiro show if you did go ahead
and hit the subscribe button so you stay
up-to-date on all of our future content